(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we are exploring the question,
are we are true selves
on screen?
(Link chuckles)
Is the Rhett and Link that
you're seeing and hearing--
- Right now.
- Or hearing right now,
the real Rhett and Link,
or some creation designed
for your entertainment?
- Much less on GMM or
like any other screen
that you may see us on.
Yeah, I think it's gonna
be some psychoanalysis
going on here perhaps.
I've got some juicy
questions for the two of us
to get into.
And this conversation is inspired
by a video that we made
where we were asking
each other questions recently,
we'll get into the details later
but I'm not gonna say we had
a disagreement afterward,
but we had, there's a few
times where we'll do a video
or have a conversation on camera
and then off camera we'll talk about it
and I just thought that that conversation
that we didn't monetize,
we should monetize.
(chuckles) Is basically--
- Oh the off camera
conversation.
- The off camera analysis
of the on camera conversation
has led to this conversation.
I'll give all the background
when we get to it,
but let's start in a lighter place.
Anywhere you wanna go, I don't know.
- So,
I was--
- Not that that's gonna be heavy.
- I got a text from my friend Ralph.
- Good ol' Ralph.
- Who I told the story
of our skiing misadventures
and how he had led me
to the top of the mountain and--
- Left you for dead.
- Trouble getting down,
I don't know, just listen to
whatever episode that was,
one of the recent ones.
And it was funny because
well, and just as a sidebar,
you can say what--
- Oh yeah.
- What Blandine had to say.
- I was telling Rhett,
I saw Blandine who was
my Spartan Race partner
for the first time since
the race this morning
'cause we go to the gym at different times
and we're not training
for a Spartan Race anymore
and Christy had shared
the podcast with her
and so she said, "I will never
hear my name the same again
"after your friend kept
saying it," and I was like--
- Blandine. (chuckles)
- It's like.
(Rhett laughs)
- I ruined her own name for her.
- And another guy was
there and I was like,
he was listening, I was like yeah,
when Rhett heard that
her name was Blandine
he made me feel weird about saying it.
Oh, Blandine.
- It's just, it's
literally my favorite name
I've ever heard.
Wow, I love it.
But anyway and then Ralph texts me--
- She enjoyed the podcast, by the way.
- Great.
- Sharing Ear Biscuits with
her friends and family.
- That is the interesting thing.
- We talk about people so that
we can increase our listenership.
- Okay, that's one way to say it.
- One person at a time,
one victim at a time.
- But there is this interesting dynamic
of when someone is talked, okay,
another example of this is
we recently told the story
of the pooping in the Tupperware.
- Oh, oh yeah. (laughs)
- And then our boys who
were present for that--
- Right.
- Started a text thread
and they're like oh, here we go again.
Every time you guys tell this
story, we have to relive it
and also tell you guys all the
details that you get wrong.
Including--
- Yeah, and the ones that
you're getting right that
you used to get wrong
and the ones that you got right
and now you're getting wrong, it's like--
- Which is just the psychological concept
of revisiting a memory and
rewriting it every time,
it's just the way humans work
but they did clarify one thing
that I'll clarify now
and that is that Greg wasn't even there.
- How did he get there?
- I think we've always
said that Greg was there.
- I don't even know.
- And somehow,
Greg wasn't there, so sorry Greg
for being thrown under
the bus all these years
and pooping in that Tupperware
that you didn't poop in.
But as is the case with
Ralph when he texted me,
he was just laughing about
how he'd listen to the thing
and he texted, in quotes,
Ralph!
With an exclamation point
because there's the moment
in the story where I yell out his name.
- Yeah.
- And then his son
had taken that moment and cut
it into this just basically--
- He made a super cut of Ralphs?
- It was just me saying Ralph!
Ralph!
- Video or just the audio?
- Video, video.
- Oh yeah, nice.
- And so Ralph
sent that to me.
So every time we talk about somebody,
there is, if they listen,
then you have to kinda deal
with whatever they
think and the super cuts
of you saying their name.
- Yeah our friendship matrix is crumbling,
I think is another way to put it.
- Which leads me to the
story that I wanna tell you
because Ralph--
- Ralph!
- Did also text me,
he said, what about the waiter story?
I was like oh crap.
- You didn't tell
the waiter story.
- I didn't tell anything
about the waiter, okay so...
We were in Mammoth, like I said,
and we had been to Mammoth
with this exact same family before.
The year before, Ralph, his wife and kids.
And so last year we went to, well,
I'm trying to think of the
best way to tell this story.
Okay--
- That's something you could
do before we do a podcast.
- No I like to just--
- That's fine.
- Pull it out of my butt
as I go.
- That's fine, yeah.
- So there's two parts
to it and I don't know
which part's better but I
think it's better to start
with part two and then tell
you how it relates to part one.
- You know what, just do
it and then Ralph's son
will edit it in the best way
later and send it to his dad.
- So here's what, so we're
eating at this restaurant,
relatively new restaurant in Mammoth
and we're all sitting, it's a big group.
There's four of us in our
family, there's five of them,
that makes nine and so we're
all sitting at this table
and you know the situation
where you're in the middle
of a conversation and a waiter
approaches the table and--
- They're kinda hovering.
- There's a little bit
of a power play that happens
and some waiters are better
at managing the situation than others
and there's also people, interestingly,
I think this might even
play into our conversations
of who's, what we're like in real life,
as an example, if you're in
the middle of saying something
in real life and a waiter comes up,
chances that you stop for
the waiter are pretty small.
If I'm telling something
and a waiter comes up,
chances are pretty high
that I'm going to stop.
That's just, you may
think that's the opposite
of the way it would be but in real life,
that's actually, it might
be 'cause you don't notice
but you're also one to be like,
I'm gonna get this thought out
and then there'll be a
break and this guy can say,
but so, somebody else was talking
and didn't see this waiter standing there.
And he stood there and
he just started going...
Like making a mouth noise.
- Chewing something?
- Was like, this is his warning system.
It was awkward, and eventually,
the conversation came to a
close and he stood there,
made one last mouth smacking noise
and then paused.
It's weird and
uncomfortable, and then said,
"Hello folks, how are you today?"
And then proceeded to do
the normal waiter things
but in a way that his energy made me feel
and everyone else feel uncomfortable.
It was just like--
- It was an animosity?
- No no, it was not an animosity at all,
it was just a weirdness.
It was a social weirdness
that just made us feel strange
and like--
- Well.
- Just pausing at certain
times and then staying
in one place and then
not leaving early enough
after you're like, you
finished a sentence.
It was like everything
was a little bit off time
in a way that just makes you
feel uncomfortable and uneasy.
So he has this interaction
with us and then he leaves
and everybody's kinda
like that was kinda weird,
and then I was like hold on a second.
I'm gonna change his name
because I legitimately
don't want this guy to
listen to this podcast.
- Call him Justin.
- Justin.
- What if his name was Justin
and I suggested it and you're like--
- It wasn't.
- Let's not call him Justin.
- I was like, our waiter's name is Justin.
- What, okay.
You just said what the waiter's name,
you knew the waiter's real
name which isn't Justin
and you said it.
- And I said last year,
at a different restaurant, we
had this exact same experience
and exact same conversation--
- Did they remember it?
- And everybody started being
like oh you're right,
that is the same guy,
the same haircut and the
mustache and it's the same guy.
It's Justin.
And he proceeds to do exactly
the same thing that he did
the first time which we
got such a kick out of it
the first time around, like
this guy was so awkward
and the way he would pause
and the way he would stay
at your table and then,
like imagine just you're
taking somebody's order
and then as you get done, you're like,
is there anything else you need?
And you're like nope and he's just like--
- It's like a robot downloading--
- He waits four seconds--
- His next line.
- Makes you feel weird
like what is going on?
And then he did it again, his
technique, new restaurant,
same technique, and--
- You think he got fired
from the other place
for his pauses and whatnot?
- No because first of all, I was like,
he came back and I was
like, Justin, right?
He was like yeah, I was like--
- I remember you, your weird
waitering from last year.
- I said, "You were
our waiter last year at
"blah blah blah blah
restaurant in Mammoth,"
and he said, "Oh yeah, I
don't miss that place."
(laughs)
- Oh.
- And okay, I don't know what happened.
I'm not gonna ask any
questions but it was just,
it was a, it was just one of those moments
that this guy left this--
- He didn't remember anything.
- Indelible mark on us
and then he did it again
and we realized deja vu
way, it was happening
at the same time and we're like no,
it's just the same guy happening
at a different restaurant.
This is what he does.
- And the moral of the story,
no there doesn't have to be a moral
but here's the freaky thing.
It reminds me of a story I
didn't tell you but from Cabo
which is very short and it's not much--
- You had a weird waiter?
- Well you know, as I explained,
I went back to the same, we
went back to the same resort
that we had gone to
like a couple of years.
Actually it may have
been three years early
the more I thought about it, okay?
And there's a restaurant at The Cape
and the first night we
were there, both times,
we've made a reservation
there 'cause it's really nice,
it's a really good restaurant.
And we went there and we
sat, they were gonna seat us
and I was like can you seat us outside?
'Cause I was thinking it was great,
it's what we did last time.
We go, we sit outside
and then all of a sudden,
the waiter comes up
and he's like asking us
have we been here, we're like yes.
We get our waters.
He goes away and I'm like, Christy.
That is the same waiter
from three years ago.
Same guy.
And then he comes back up and we're like,
we're looking at him and
before we say anything,
he was like, you've been here before.
And he remembered us but
he wasn't weird at all.
He just gained some weight
so he looked different.
- I'm gonna keep this going,
because your story reminds
me of another small story
from my recent trip to Cabo.
- What?
- Yes.
- Hey, this is an all new
way to do a whole podcast.
That reminds me--
- Of a story that's not
that great that I'm gonna tell.
- No, this one's good.
- Okay.
But before you tell it, I
will just say that like,
we felt a special
connection with this guy,
like our first night in
Cabo, our first time,
it was like it kinda made
the evening that like,
oh and he said, "I remember you
'cause it was my first day."
- What?
- "Of working here."
- Even better.
- And so we were special to
him, he was special to us.
The food was special, the
whole thing was special.
- And he was like and this is my last day.
No that didn't happen?
- No we were like,
when are you off the clock?
- You wanna hang?
- We invited him up
to our room, we all got
in the bath tub together.
- Oh cool.
- It was very special.
I don't know why I
didn't mention it before.
- Yeah, right.
- Very special.
- Okay we'll skip
that last part.
So--
- Full service there
at the resort.
- Oh, I go to a restaurant
at the resort on the first
night and it's the restaurant
at the main restaurant.
And we get this waiter
and he's a good waiter.
He's not weird, nothing
particularly notable about him.
But we order two, each order a cocktail,
then we order two appetizers
and then we each order an
entree and then we each order,
then we order two desserts, okay,
this is a pretty complex order.
We stay at the resort for three days.
The last night, we go
back to the restaurant
and we get the same waiter.
He says, "Oh, you're back."
Like yeah, I mean this is the resort,
this is the restaurant at the resort.
- Yeah, full circle.
I'm kinda trapped here.
- He said, "How's your
stay," whatever, he was like,
I can tell you what you
ordered the other night.
And he went through every
single item and was right.
- And you were like,
I'll take none of that
'cause I've already had it.
- And I said, "Well we
wanna get completely
"different things this time."
But hold on but--
- There's a through line
with all these stories, it's like--
- That's interesting, is it not?
- It is interesting when it's happening
but then when you re-tell
it, I'm just gonna be honest,
the more I thought about it--
- No no no.
- You went to a place in Mammoth.
You were served by a waiter,
you went to another place,
he moved restaurants.
I went to a place three years later.
It's not unheard of that a
waiter would still be working
at a place three years later
and it's not unheard of a
few days later that even--
- The whole--
- Big order.
- No.
- He would remember.
Did you make him go through it?
- Yes, he said, I think
it's a party trick.
He was like, I can tell you what you had
and he went through
everything, cocktails--
- So maybe that's the more
impressive of the three stories.
- Hold on, it's one thing
to be one of those waiters
who remembers your order
and doesn't write it down
which always makes me nervous, by the way.
But this guy remembered the
order from three days before.
He's got multiple customers a night.
- Yeah.
- That's crazy.
- Well, that's--
- He should be like on a math team.
- That's pretty impressive.
- Like a memory team.
He shouldn't be a waiter.
- That justifies the rabbit
trail we've just gone down.
I'll say that.
- Okay, we are gonna
not, we're not gonna talk
about waiters anymore.
- But hold on, I just remembered.
We did experience another
waiter that remembered us
one time when we went somewhere.
Remember he remembered us?
We were with Stevie,
we were like traveling
and we were freaking out.
- Well so the way we're
gonna end this is--
- When a waiter remembers you--
- This is a fourth story that doesn't--
- It freaks you out.
- Doesn't really amount
to anything.
- But then when you tell it,
it's kinda like--
- I think all our stories were
great until that last one.
- It's a you had to be there kinda thing.
That's a great podcast.
I'm gonna tell you stories that
you really have to be there
to appreciate.
- We're gonna talk about
whether or not we are
our true selves on screen
but first we're gonna let
you know that Link is wearing
a shirt from our storywear collection.
- Yeah.
- The Post-Apawcalypse.
- That's right.
In a post apocalyptic
world, dogs take over
because humans are relegated as pets.
I ain't complainin'.
- And there's a whole series,
there's a whole collection.
There's multiple shirts that are t-shirts.
There's--
- Pants.
- There's sweatpants.
- There's a bandana.
- There's a button-up
shirt, there's a bandana.
What else is there?
- There's a denim shirt.
- A denim, well you gotta button it.
- Check it out.
- You gotta button it.
- Bandanas.
- Bandanas--
- Every item tells a story.
- Complete your story with
storywear at Mythical.store.
- Okay so,
here's how I want to set this up.
If you don't know, we got this thing
called the Mythical Society,
it is a secret society.
MythicalSociety.com, check it out.
We're doing vlogs over there,
one a month, exclusive,
where we're talking directly
to the society members
but one of the things that
we did was we got questions,
suggestions for questions submitted
that we would ask each other
and one of those questions
that was asked for you
to ask me just led to an,
I haven't watched the vlog back.
I mean you can watch it
yourself but we'll unpack it
a little bit but it kinda
led to a conversation
that led to a post conversation.
Meaning a second conversation off camera
after that conversation where we,
I just thought there were some emotions
that bubbled to the
surface that I just thought
it would be interesting
for us to talk about.
So here was the question.
They asked Rhett, Rhett can you ask Link,
can you ask Cotton Candy
Randy to be nicer to Link?
- Right.
- And that was the question that, hold on,
that you asked me, right?
- I--
- No, I asked you
that question.
And then you started to
answer it and then I was like,
and you were like, what
do you think about it?
I think that's how it went.
- Well regardless, I can't
remember who asked who
the question but it was, a
fan wanted Cotton Candy Randy
to be nicer to Link and I
don't know whether that person
was just asking a joke question
or if they were serious,
but so that specific person
I don't know what they
were going for but for me,
that made me think about the fact that
I do see, first of all,
we already know that like,
Cotton Candy Randy is very polarizing
because he's a negative energy,
there's just some people
who aren't into that and so,
there's a lot of people who don't like him
and there's people who
really, really like him.
In fact, there are lots of people who,
of all the things that
we've ever done comedically
in the world of Good Mythical Morning,
Cotton Candy Randy is their favorite thing
because it's the most subversive thing,
well one of the most subversive
things that we've done
and it kinda goes against
type that we've established
on GMM in a lot of ways
so a lot of people just,
that's their thing and
they really like it.
- Yeah he's a twisted
and demented character
whose head and facial hair
is made out of cotton candy
and when kids eat too much candy,
he's gonna show up and whisper
sweet nothings in their ear,
meaning he is going to terrorize them
throughout their sleep cycle.
He's like a anti tooth fairy.
- And he, one notable thing about him is
he really dislikes you.
- Yeah.
- The bit is--
- He really likes you.
- Is that he, well,
he likes to whisper things to me and I,
regardless of how demented they are,
always seem to enjoy it, right?
- You really enjoy it, yeah.
- And then you,
he always says very mean things to you
and apparently he wants you dead.
I mean that's, I think
that's Cotton Candy Randy
in a nutshell, and I thought
this was an opportunity,
what I was doing at
the time is I was like,
you know, this is a inside conversation,
Mythical Society, that's one of the things
that's about is like
let's have a conversation
that we wouldn't
necessarily have elsewhere,
probably on Ear Biscuits maybe but anyway,
so I said, what I was
trying to do is I was trying
to set you up so that you could say
what I want to hear because you know me,
I of course love Cotton Candy Randy.
I like subversive things.
That kinda comedy really appeals to me
and I get legitimately annoyed with people
who have a problem with that.
Now, I don't expect, there's
nothing wrong with you
if you don't like him and I know
in comedy he's incredibly polarizing
and I don't expect everybody
to like him and in fact,
one of the reasons I do
like him is because I know
that people don't like him,
that's how my brain works.
- But there may be something,
so there's nothing wrong with
respecting someone else's
comedic opinion of Cotton Candy Randy
but there may be
something wrong and we'll,
there may be another thing
that you're taking issue with
which is a misunderstanding
of what's going on.
The thing that you did was,
you asked me the question,
you kinda threw the ball
to me, you were like,
so what would you say to that, Link?
Do you think that's a
good idea or whatever,
and I was like well,
I think that would be silly
to ask Cotton Candy Randy
to be nice to me because Cotton
Candy Randy is a character.
- Right.
- And the reason why we
interpreted it that way that someone was
asking it sincerely is
because there are a lot
of seemingly sincere comments online,
I think you see 'em a lot more than I do
because they may be, I don't know why,
if you're looking for them
or if they @ you but not me
or something, or maybe
I just don't read 'em,
but because another way
to interpret it was,
it would be a funny bit if
you asked Cotton Candy Randy
to be nice to Link, which
that might be a good choice.
That may be a good suggestion
but I'm pretty sure
that's not what was behind the question.
- And what it kinda led to for me was,
okay, obviously there is a certain dynamic
between the two of us and we kind of
and this is why we're
having this conversation
because it plays into the greater question
that we're asking today which is
are we our true selves on camera?
There's a, in the comedic
duo of who we are,
there is a certain dynamic
where you kinda play this role
where you are, if we're gonna
do a bit that's on brand
or according to type--
- Yeah on type.
- If the show is doing a prank,
it's probably gonna be done on you, right?
If we're gonna have a pill
that makes you lose the ability
to taste spicy foods like
we did that one episode,
well, it's probably gonna
be the most true to type
if I'm in the know and you don't know
and we're playing the prank on you, right?
And so, that's just, now first,
obviously we can do it the opposite way
and it goes against type and it's funny
for a different reason, but also,
if we have a character
like Cotton Candy Randy,
and this wasn't a discussion,
nobody ever discussed this.
Jordan invented Cotton Candy Randy.
- Yeah we never said he's gonna--
- How he was gonna act--
- Like Rhett,
he's gonna hate Link.
- But as he entered into
the dynamic of Rhett and Link,
his natural sort of comedic
inclination was that
wouldn't it be funny if I just hated Link
and whispered weird
things to Rhett and so,
there's enough of that kind
of thing that has happened
over the years that there is a segment
of the Mythical Beasts who are like
why you gotta be picking on Link?
Why is Link the butt of so many jokes?
- Right.
- And so what I was asking you
to do as, from a comedy standpoint--
- Yes.
- Is to basically say,
hey guys, that's part of our comedy
and you shouldn't feel sorry for me.
- Right, so--
- Right.
- As a side note, I think
that the spicy pill prank
that was played on me was a bad example
and we should come back to it.
So let's not forget to come back to that
'cause I think that
that's, that doesn't work.
But it's a good analysis--
- Doesn't work
in this context?
- It doesn't prove your point.
Once we analyze it later, but
the Cotton Candy Randy thing,
I mean it's obviously Jordan, of course
if you don't know Jordan, somebody who's,
it's not a dude, it's a fake
beard made out of cotton candy,
it is a character.
- Yeah he's not a real person.
- So we've entered this mode where
it's not scripted, it's totally improv,
but it's, we're not being
ourselves, we're just playing,
we're playing things for
comedic effect entirely so,
but the thing that I found interesting was
even though I gave the right answer,
it was a little bit different
than what you were looking for
and that's fine but I
think it's fascinating
so that's the only reason
I wanna talk about it.
'Cause I said my answer was, well,
if you ask Cotton Candy
Randy to be nice to me,
I think that's a silly
request because obviously
the comedy is in, and this
is me talking to them,
the comedy is in him being mean to me,
that's just, it's funny.
And me acting as if my
feelings are hurt is part
of the comedy too, like
that sells it, right?
And I'm like, I wanted to
give everyone the benefit
of the doubt, I didn't wanna,
it doesn't get to me
as much it does to you
so then at that point I didn't
tap into any frustration.
I was just like, I wanna
give them the benefit
of the doubt and say, now,
I don't have to tell you
that he's a character and
that we just made that choice
but I do think there's people out there
who are issuing complaints and who--
- Yeah.
- Think that, but you know,
then you went into this bit about,
well but do you like the sympathy?
And I just, I think
what was behind that is,
you get more frustrated than
I do and I respect that.
Because it's like, well, maybe
you should articulate it.
- Well I think--
- What about it frustrates you
because I think it's a valid frustration.
- Well I mean, I think
there's a lot of things
that fall under this umbrella.
Somebody not getting the
joke always frustrates me.
Somebody saying,
again, this is a--
- I think when you become,
when you don't get the
joke it's kinda like,
oh I'm a comedian and
it didn't work but then
when the byproduct is you're the bad guy.
- Yeah.
- It's kinda frustrating
when people, I mean...
The Mythical Beasts aren't that rude
but they feel like they
need to take up for me
and they direct it at you.
- I feel like, and again, I'm
probably generalizing, right,
and I'm not, even though we know a lot
of Mythical Beasts by
name or by Twitter handle
and that kinda thing, no
individuals come to mind
so it's not like I have
any grudges against anybody
but it seems to me, in my mind,
what I've constructed in my mind is that
there's a certain fan who,
what they like about us is just
what they perceive as the
genuine Rhett and Link.
But when it comes to our
comedy that we're actually,
when we're trying to be comedians--
- Right.
- And making comedic choices
like thoughtful comedic
choices that are more
of an artistic approach,
they're kinda like,
I don't like that,
like they don't like
our local commercials.
There's a whole segment
of people, in fact,
one of the reasons we stopped
making our local commercials
is because we just couldn't deal
with so many people misunderstanding
what we were trying to do comedically.
Interestingly, when we hang out with
legitimate comedians,
professional comedians,
a lot of times the only point
of reference they have from us
is our local commercials
and so in our minds,
from a comedic standpoint
is those local commercials
that we made--
- That's a craft.
- It's the, potentially the
best work we've ever done
but there's a not an
insignificant percentage
of Mythical Beasts who are like,
that's the stupidest thing
that you guys have ever done.
And so that, I can't
come up with an analogy
but it's almost just like,
if you consider yourself
to be an artist and you're like,
my best work is this
thing and then this thing
that I kinda do incidentally,
that's the thing that
you're all connecting with
and you're not connecting with this thing
that actually was
really, really thoughtful
and is my best effort.
And then I think it
carries over to, again,
I think it's taking us
so seriously as people
that it's just like well
sometimes the bit between us
as a duo is that
my character is going to make fun of you
and say mean things,
or some other character in our universe
like Cotton Candy Randy's
gonna say mean things
and then I get tweets
and I see comments about,
why's he gotta be so mean
to Link and I'm like, guys.
It's a freaking joke.
- And I think here
on Ear Biscuits--
- And that just frustrates me.
- Yeah.
I think you can anticipate
that Ear Biscuits
is a much more real version of who we are
so I'm not holding anything
that you don't already know
so in this environment,
I think that I definitely make
fun of you a lot more here
and the real you than I do on the show.
Because, but we both know that
there's comedy in that here
'cause we're not just totally talking,
we're making fun of each
other because it's funny.
But in the context of GMM,
so much of the strength of the show rides
on the impromptu honestly of the moments,
like there's so many
things that happen that
by design we don't know.
I think we've talked about this before.
But there are times when
we go into comedy bits
and there's...
That balance shifts from moment to moment.
There are entire episodes that are planned
like when you go into a conspiracy thing
about how Finland doesn't exist.
Okay, bombshell, can you
please come clean about
what you think about Finland?
- You mean the country that doesn't exist?
- He has a choice to make here.
Do you really believe--
- Yeah and--
- Can you say it?
Of course.
- I think that most people
probably, I would say that
90, there's definitely 1%
of the people watching who think
that I legitimately believe
the conspiracy theories
and there's nothing I'm ever--
- Just say it.
You don't believe what?
- I believe that Finland
is a real country.
- Oh, he did it.
That was a big milestone.
No it's not because, and you kinda know,
you've suspended your disbelief
and we're going into this
bit and we like to do it.
Does it get the most views?
No but it's a comedic choice, you know--
- And I'm actually making--
- It's more craft work.
- And I'm actually--
- Like the band.
- I'm actually very unlikely
to believe conspiracy
theories in real life.
- Yeah you're making fun, yeah.
- I'm an extreme--
- You probably should have
changed your name and--
- I'm an extreme skeptic right
and so I actually find
conspiracy theorists to be funny.
Like I find them funny.
- Well I mean in terms of--
- And so I think that they're--
- But in terms of a mode you
look at The Colbert Report.
Not the show now but the
transition is fascinating
because that was brilliant.
I mean there's a reason
why I think it won Emmys
or should have, and he did
because it was absolutely
brilliant what he did.
- Right, but--
- And it worked on
a number of levels.
So we aspire to things like that.
- What is the Venn diagram
of the people who don't like
Cotton Candy Randy who also
don't like Stephen Colbert?
I would say there is
a very high crossover.
That--
- I know so I think
what you're getting at is I
think the frustration is that
there are people in our
GMM audience who they,
and I think I understand
why they're like that,
they wanna take everything at face value
because we present it that way.
I think that, I think
the reason why I wanted
to have this conversation is if some
of those people are listening or watching,
that we can kind of educate
where we're coming from
to free them up to enjoy
more of the entire breadth
of what GMM is and also to kinda alleviate
your frustration a little bit.
I think that's kinda my
ulterior motive in this thing.
There's also this complaint
about the show being scripted
which again is a different thing.
But I think it's related a little bit.
And again, we go out in and
out of scripted moments.
We shouldn't have to, I
think people are so attached
to the impromptu honesty of the show that
if there's anything that's
planned, like I can tell
that they had thought about
that joke ahead of time,
like well, we could be better
at delivering some jokes
sometimes but, and the top of the show,
we plan out what we're
gonna say so that we can get
into it quicker so we can
just be more succinct.
They're just different modes in the show
that I think, I think it's an opportunity
to make it more fun to say, okay,
I don't know exactly,
it's all about sensing
what mode we're working in.
And then saying, sometimes
it's blurry and it kinda shifts
and I think that's a
fun aspect of the show
so I get frustrated when people criticize
when we're not just acting
in the 100% impromptu mode,
you know, the entire 100% unplanned mode.
I won't say honest, I'll say unplanned
'cause I do think there's a difference.
- Right and I probably personally
receive the brunt of that complaint more
simply because...
Okay, we did fact-based games on GMM.
We did it back and forth
for a really long time,
but those of you who've
sort of observed patterns
of GMM probably learned that okay,
if we're gonna play a fact-based game,
I host it and you play it.
That's just what we've arrived at.
- Right.
- And because we each
fit those roles better
than the other, right?
It's like, you not having
any clue as to what
I'm going to ask and what you're gonna say
sets you up to say really funny things.
Funnier things than I would be saying
if I was just thinking of
things off the top of my head.
But I'm pretty good at saying jokes
that I thought about ahead of time.
So I think that,
I don't know, I mean it's,
I don't sit around
thinking about this a lot,
but there is this sort of underlying thing
that I just kind of understand
that there is some percentage
and I don't know what it is,
of people who kinda perceive it,
perceive the show in that way
and then a lot of that
is kinda focused at me
because I'm the one that's
the source of those things.
I might be the source of
more of the scripted jokes,
I might be a source of
more of the negative,
the negative energy when
it comes to the humor.
And so people who are
like I don't like that,
I don't like anything that's negative,
I don't like anything that's scripted.
It's just like okay well,
I don't like what Rhett
brings to the show.
So I think that when I
talk about those things,
I end up kind of, that's where
the frustration comes from.
- I think that we have such a wide range
in age that watches the show.
There's a level of maturity
required to start to parse
the different modes that we work in
and get to the point that I'm asking for
which is that it becomes
something that you appreciate
and enjoy, the question mark of...
I do think that's, there's
certain things like
when we're blindfolded or
when we're playing a game
and we're not supposed to know stuff,
I'll just go on record and
say that we don't cheat.
I know Stevie cheated that one time,
it was a joke on us and
you played the joke on me
with the pill which again
I'll get back to later,
but we don't cheat when it comes to games
and things like that.
- Yeah, things where the
idea is that we're not in on,
we're not in on it,
then we're not in on it,
like on purpose, like we
keep things from ourselves
so that we can have authentic reactions
to the things that we need to.
- But I wanna tell you a
story of a conversation I had
with Lando which helped me...
I just came to a realization
about how he perceived me,
how he perceived the show,
and then I ended up talking
to Lily and Christy about it.
I invited him on the show
to kick me in the balls
when we were doing the,
testing the jock straps
'cause the plan was
you were gonna get Shep
to kick you in the balls,
Lando was gonna kick me.
And if you watch that episode,
Shep ended up kicking
both of us in the balls
'cause as I explained, Lando
said he didn't wanna do it.
And then in Good Mythical
More he did come on
and he said a little bit
more about it but that night,
I was tucking him in bed and like,
I got in bed with him and I
was just hanging out beside him
and we could have more of a conversation.
It was one of those
things where it's like,
it's not your bedtime yet but go ahead
and get ready for bed, that way it's not,
'cause I wanna go to bed earlier too.
So we had a few minutes to have
a longer conversation than normal.
And we were laying there and he said,
"Do you still hurt from
getting hit this morning?"
Meaning when Shepherd hit me in the balls,
now, I mean he kicked me in the balls.
I don't even know if all
the times he kicked me
in the balls made the edit
'cause he would kinda,
we had to cut out times
we would kinda miss,
but he gave me two direct hits.
And I crumple over on
the ground and I'm like,
I gave anything on America's
Funniest Home Videos
a run for their money
because it was a direct hit.
My crotch is lower to
the ground than yours.
I don't think he took that into account.
- What you trying to say?
- You're taller than me and
I'm more of a man than you.
- Oh, that's what you're saying.
- My crotch hangs lower.
- Okay.
- It was all crumpled up in a cup, let's--
- Yeah it was protected.
- But then the cup
hitting the sides of your,
what is that called, it's not the taint
'cause it's on the right and left side.
The raighnt and the
leighnt, right and left.
- I don't think we need--
- That's where the ball,
where the cup hits.
- I don't think we need an explanation.
I think everybody understands.
- It was the most
sincere, tender question,
no pun intended.
Do you still hurt from
when you got hit today?
And I was like, well it did hurt.
But not as bad as I made it sound.
I wanted to tell him
that because I could tell
how concerned he was for
me, it was like super cute.
I was also honest, it did hurt,
but not as bad as I made
it seem, and he said,
"Well why would you make
it hurt more than it did?"
And I said,
"To be funny."
(Rhett chuckles)
And he didn't laugh.
He got this puzzled look on his face
and he was just kinda like,
he could not make sense of it.
And I said, "I did it
to make the show funny."
And he said, "Do you
know what Bitcoin is?"
(laughs)
And I was like, I was like
I'm not gonna sit here
and explain to you what Bitcoin is.
It's your bedtime.
Like, you're not--
- That was the end
of the conversation?
- I'm not gonna fall
for this trick.
And I was like, so do
you know what it means?
Do you know what Bitcoin is?
And,
he said, "No."
He was like, do you know what Bitcoin is?
I'm like, okay I guess
I am falling for this.
- He doubted that you
knew what Bitcoin was.
- I thought for a second,
I was like no, not really,
well, I mean it's cryptocurrency.
And he was like, oh so you
do know what Bitcoin means.
And I was like, well yeah, I do.
He was like, well then why on your show
did you keep guessing Bitcoin
for the answer to the question?
And I remembered, we
played a game where we had
to fill in the blank on something
and he was watching at home,
he wasn't there that day
and I kept writing in
Bitcoin as the answer.
- Yeah, I don't know what
game it was, I remember.
- And I remembered that when he asked me
if I knew what Bitcoin was,
why would I keep giving it
as the answer for other questions.
And I was like, to be funny.
- You teaching him comedy?
- And I could see the wheels turning
and I could tell, I was like, oh wow.
My own son is realizing that
his dad is not as stupid
as he thought he was.
(Rhett laughs)
- Oh that's hilarious.
- And I was like,
if he would have
understood this yesterday,
he'd have kicked me in
the balls this morning.
So that's what I should
have explained to him.
- You think he would have?
- I think so, yeah.
Now, so for the record, it did hurt.
It really hurt.
But I also took full advantage
of the comedic opportunity
presented to me to convey the fact
that it was shockingly painful.
- Oh, it was, Jacob just pointed out,
that was on--
- He was in that episode.
- It was the holiday list.
- He was there.
He does watch the show if he's not in it
but he was physically present there
and that's why he remembered
the Bitcoin thing,
and he'd been puzzling
on it for all this time.
So yeah I'm like dang, you
must think I'm kinda stupid.
Yeah I'm not as stupid,
but then I went out
and I tucked him in, so he went to sleep
and then I went into Lily's
room to tell her goodnight
and I ended up telling
her what I just told you.
Probably in a truncated version.
There were no sponsors involved.
And she was laughing
and I was like, I mean,
do you think I'm stupid?
(Rhett laughs)
- This is funny.
- And I'm like,
I kinda really wanna
know, I was like, well,
the what age do my kids start
realizing I'm not stupid?
And I ended up talking to
her and Christy about it
and they, it wasn't an
easy answer. (laughs)
'Cause, very quickly one of
the things they brought up was,
well you know, Dad, remember
when we watched that video,
Link struggling for
seven minutes straight.
- From @Youresoloud?
- @Youresoloud made.
- [Rhett] He puts different
hair on and then he takes it off
at this point and realize,
and reveals, hey I'm--
- That I tweeted because
I thought it was so funny,
like we're all laughing
our heads off and like,
I think I tweeted that Christy was like,
welcome to every day
of my life kinda thing.
And I think the point was
that we discussed was that
well, in some ways you might be.
(Rhett chuckles)
As stupid as you are
on the show and this is
coming from the people
that love me the most
and I guess felt safe enough to tell me.
They knew watching that cut
down and living with me,
like Christy said, welcome to my life,
that it's not like that all the time,
but it's definitely like
that some of the time.
I mean, I think...
And I was like well, I
got a little defensive
and I was like, well,
it's not that I'm stupid,
it's just that
I can suspend my intelligence.
(Rhett laughs)
- Wow, that's good.
- I think that's what I do.
You know, if you're watching
a movie or something,
you suspend your disbelief.
I suspend my intelligence,
I can disconnect the things
that would stop me from saying things,
that I just say on instinct
or wielding sharp objects
in a way that no one has business doing.
I can just turn that off
and say, you know what,
this is the mode that I operate in.
- Well but I think that
stupid is the wrong word
for those things, I mean--
- If you're gonna come
up with a harsher word--
- No, I mean I think that like, okay,
the thing that Christy
probably deals with,
is she would probably
call you absent-minded.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
- I ask her where stuff is
that's in my pocket all the time.
- Right, which is not stupid.
I mean like there are...
Einstein was probably absent-minded.
The absent-minded
professor, it's not stupid.
But then things like the,
like when you put the cat,
I don't remember what
happened when you spit,
you drank water.
- [Crew] No no no no no no.
- What?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that was the wrong end.
I drank--
- You drank cat water
through a thing--
- Poop water.
- And then you put your
mouth back on the thing.
- Yeah.
- That's not an--
- My intelligence was suspended.
- That's what you're saying for that?
To me, I don't think that that's stupid,
I just think that that is,
like an accident-prone.
- Cautiouslessly impulsive.
- Yeah I don't know what the
word is but I just think it's,
you are more likely to injure yourself
with a knife than I am,
but you're not gonna injure--
- And I have in real life, I
mean the stories that I tell.
- It isn't that--
- Are true stories.
- It isn't like you can't
actually ever hold a knife,
it's just that no, because Link
is the one who's more likely
to do something with a
knife, it's a funny bit
that every time he has a sharp object,
I'm going to take it from him because
that's taking something that isn't untrue,
which I think is kinda
getting to the bigger question
that we're asking,
is taking something that is based in truth
and exaggerating it
for the sake of comedy.
And that is, I mean, incidentally,
that's what we do whenever
we script something.
That's what--
- We even go further.
- The second season of Buddy System.
- Yeah was like three notches above that.
- It isn't like--
- In a thought exercise
alternate universe, we never
knew each other kinda way.
- Right, and it's just like,
it was extreme caricatures,
right, your character was
an extreme caricature of you
in a way that people may not even be able
to follow the logic to get to that point,
to understand why we ended up,
maybe even more so with my character
in like the weird hippie
stuff and the man bun
and all this stuff, but all
that kinda came out of well,
I am the one that kinda
gets into some new idea
or philosophy and learns
a lot about and adopts it
and suddenly starts trying
to tell you about it
and that kinda thing, and so
if I were to do that unhinged,
unimpeded, I might
eventually get to a place
where I was this weird dude who wore
all these weird clothes and
adopted this weird religion.
- What do you think,
what's your question to my,
is Link as stupid in real
life as he is on the show?
I elected to frame it in that harsh way.
I'll let you come up with your
own but what's your version
of that question?
Is Rhett as blank in real
life as he is on the show?
- Probably smart.
- Oh God.
(Rhett laughs)
Okay, pivot that.
- Is Rhett as self-absorbed?
- I don't think that that
comes across in the show.
I'm not gonna-- (chuckles)
- No it's like no it's like--
- Try again.
- One--
- I don't think that's it.
- No but one--
- 'Cause I don't think that
comes across in the show.
I do have something in mind.
- But let me explain though.
Like...
Like a know-it-all quality
of like being confident
and cocky about being
able to do something.
Like that's an element of my character
but it's also an element
of my personality.
That comes from who I am but no,
I am not that way in my
interpersonal interactions
with normal, everyday people.
I'm that way when I'm
in my comedic element.
- I don't think that
comes across on the show.
I think it could come across
in real life at times,
but that's now what we're talking about.
I think it's more of, here's my pitch.
Is Rhett just as mean, I think
that's the criticism again,
is Rhett as mean in real
life as he is on the show?
Link is stupid and Rhett is mean.
It's like, that's what
you're saying that you get
the criticism that why
you so mean to Link?
You know, it's like--
- Yeah.
I would--
- And I don't,
maybe that's not the right one either.
- I mean okay if we go down that path,
I would say that...
I would think that no one that knows me,
I would say that if people
who are my best friends
were to list my top 10
negative attributes,
I would be willing to bet a
significant amount of money
that one of those top 10
would not be that I'm mean.
I think that that is,
I am not a mean person.
That's not, I'm actually--
- Right.
- I'm actually, in my
estimation, too nice of a person.
We've talked about this before
that I'm a people pleaser
and I laugh at people's
jokes when they're not funny
and I try to accommodate
people who are being awkward
and stuff like that.
So I'm not a mean person but I think
in the context of our characters,
and also the context of us as--
- Maybe it's just intensity.
'Cause I don't think that mean is,
I think that's a criticism
that's leveled against you
but I don't think that's
a character trait.
That's a misinterpretation
of what we've already,
the comedic bits that
we've already talked about.
But an intensity that's
like, the furrowed brow
and the--
- I mean.
- And you're not grumpy on
the show either so it's like.
Maybe you're just stupid
too, just go with that.
Are you as stupid in real
life as I am in the show?
(chuckles)
- I mean what is your estimation on that?
'Cause I haven't thought
about this specifically.
I think a lot about the
fact that if people were to
just look at the two of us
and how we present ourselves
on the internet, that they would be like,
Rhett seems like, I guess
mean is not the word
that I would use but
let's just go with that.
Rhett seems like he would be mean.
Link seems like he would be really nice.
- Yeah.
- And then of course, my argument is that,
well, that's not true.
- I also think, here's what I think it is.
I think you are much
closer to your true self
on the show than I am.
I think that there's more of a,
that there's more of a
heightened thing with me,
with my character on the show.
I think that's maybe more my opinion.
- Yeah I think that--
- And then when you go
against type, that's funny--
- But I think that most
of the people who would
characterize me as mean on the show
would probably characterize
me as mean in real life.
- Right that's what I'm saying
because they misinterpret--
- Because again--
- Just being intense.
- There are some people
who don't respond well
to intensity at all.
And like me and you deal with that.
I get passionate and intense about things
and then people who have more
sensitive personality types
tend to take intensity personally.
- Yeah.
- Like me and you have
had to work through that
as we've discussed
things, it's just like--
- And you tend to be more
focused on the rightness
of something or the correctness
of something than the...
Whether it's right or wrong
versus the way it's presented.
- And it's more,
are we haven't a
philosophical conversation
or are we having a personal conversation?
- Right.
- And so and this is not, again,
this is just part of
my personality makeup.
This is part of the personality
makeup that I'm addressing
in therapy to one degree 'cause I'm very,
very much in my head and
spend a lot of time up here
thinking about things and
then I don't translate
those things into feelings
and they end up kinda coming
up sideways in certain ways.
- But I think that people, I think,
well I'll speak about you
first and then I'll speak
about myself but I think
that you harness...
People resonate and might
be more of a fan of you
than me if the ideas and
the, the ideas resonate more.
It's like I'm not gonna give a lot of,
not as much of ideas in
the way that you are.
I think that again, when
the comedy comes mostly
from your head, it's gonna
have a certain flavor to it
that I think mine comes
from a different place.
That's why I stopped posting the episodes.
The fact-based episodes because we find
how our makeup leads into
our comedic strengths.
So we're able to say in a room,
you know what, it would be better
if I never hosted another
one of those 'cause Rhett,
you're so much better at it,
and it's better for me not
to know what's happening
and with this free wheeling response,
we're hoping to capture something.
- Mm-hmm.
- Right,
and that's a good, that's
the best that we have both
of those things we contribute.
And I don't know if I've
said this on podcast before
but I remember that, you know,
it kinda felt like it hurt
at the moment where I,
it felt like it was admitting,
yeah I can't do that,
so that's one less thing I can do.
I kinda suck at that, you know.
As opposed to, and then, I
had to go through a process
of coming to grips with and being secure
in the strengths that I did have to offer
in saying this is the perfect
way to allow for that.
- Well and to--
- For both of us I guess.
- To platform you, like I said.
First of all, once we get
going in certain modes,
both of us being reactive and
in the moment really works.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But--
- It's not that I never have ideas
and it's not that you never
have hilarious reactions.
- But if we have to push
ourselves into a corner
and say okay, well one
of, if we're gonna create
a situation in where one
person knows what's happening
and is operating according to a plan,
and one person doesn't
know what's happening,
who's going to flourish in those?
- Who's gonna know about
the pill and who's not?
- Right and Link is going to be funnier,
and again, that's kinda why I thought that
that was an example.
I know what you're saying,
it's not an example
of you playing a character.
- Yeah we were not choosing comedic sides.
- But you are going to--
- I didn't choose anything.
It was a legitimate
prank and I fell for it.
- You are going, the things
that you're going to say
in that moment where you're
trying to convince yourself
that this thing works,
it's gonna be funnier
than what I'm gonna say.
- But I also--
- 10 out of 10 times--
- I also don't think that the chances
of successfully convincing
you of that were very low
and the chances of convincing
me of it were also very high.
- Right, there's a high
chance that in the midst
of that, I would be like,
this is a prank, and two reasons.
Well, I think it's
ultimately just one reason.
I think it's because if I begin to suspect
that it's a prank, I'm
probably gonna point it out.
Even if you did begin to
suspect it was a prank,
you would suspend your
intelligence. (chuckles)
- Yes.
- And go with this bit
and continue to carry it out whereas,
I don't have that in me.
- So for the record I did not do that.
- Right, you, we got you.
We really got you.
- You got me.
- And that's when it's funniest.
- I still haven't watched that one back.
I would watch that one back.
- Well and because it's not as funny
when you have to do it intentionally.
It's funnier when you're being authentic.
- And that would be a
hard thing to do anyway,
but you know, I do feel like people--
- But you know what--
- People feel sorry for me
and that's the thing that
I do want to address.
- Well but before we get
to that because I do think,
to play into the question,
I knew that it would be funny
in the context of the show,
but if there wasn't a camera there
and I was just like, I'm gonna prank,
I do not, we don't prank each other.
Again, this is a little
bit what's on screen
and what's in real life?
We don't prank each other.
We've never pranked each other.
It isn't in our makeup to
be like I'm gonna take time
just for the hell of it
to just prank you at work
just to see what the reaction is.
And a lot of it has to with the fact that
so much of what we do is a
product that people can see
and so if we're gonna take the time
to do something like that,
to engineer something,
well, you can bet that
it's going to be online.
But it's also just like,
that's not our personalities.
It's not our personalities
to find some way
to mess with each other like that.
And also, if I were to do that,
if I were to, for some reason to decide
that I was gonna prank you,
your reaction to a prank
that wasn't being filmed would
be like 10% as entertaining
as your reaction to a prank
if you were being filmed and you knew it.
And it isn't because you're acting,
it's just that when you're
on and when the camera's on--
- I just don't have that much energy.
- You're in a mode where
you're like, I'm reacting,
I'm processing things out loud
and that is a recipe for entertainment.
- And you know what--
- Whereas,
if you're just by yourself, you're just,
we're both rather boring.
(Link chuckles)
I mean, if you were to put a
hidden camera in our office
and just see what
happens on a daily basis,
the way that we work
through create problems,
the conversations that
we have, you'd be like,
I feel like I'm looking at
professor's office hours.
- Ha, I got you!
I got you!
I've had a camera in our
office for like two years.
- You can release that,
it'd be very boring.
- And it's so boring.
I got you, man.
You know, the thing is,
I feel like I've been, I don't know,
I've been thinking more about this.
It's funny, you do 1500 episodes of a show
and you feel like there's
nothing you can learn
and you're just on autopilot
but I don't think that's the case at all,
I think that these are things that,
I remember we used to get in fights, man.
Like in Fuquay when we first
started doing Chia Lincoln,
like we'd be telling stories
and we wouldn't like,
I wouldn't like a way
that you said something
or you wouldn't like how I cut you off
and didn't let you finish a story or,
we would just...
We had so much to learn but the thing
that I'm learning now
is I'm actually seeing,
and maybe this plays into
people feeling sorry for me
'cause I don't want people
to feel sorry for me
and say oh, Link's the butt of the joke
or everybody thinks he's stupid,
or maybe he is stupid
and I feel sorry for him.
I don't want any of that
because I think I've actually...
The game show thing is a good example.
But in pretty much every episode,
I'm finding out how,
more of my true instincts
can be harnessed for comedy,
and so the more honest I am,
and I think I've been
thinking about it more
since we talked about the Instagram thing.
When you talked about dude,
you just do what you wanna do
on Instagram, like you
planning out something is,
you're short-circuiting
your own comedic process.
So dance like nobody's watching.
Anyway, I actually think
that, in the exercise
of doing that within the context of GMM
and understanding what I'm trying to do
that I'm just trying to...
Thinking of it as
suspending my intelligence
and knowing that like
okay, I'm not an idiot.
I'm actually smart for
being able to harness
just raw instinct in this way.
I actually feel better
about it. (chuckles)
But then a step further, I actually
feel like that the show me
is kind of a gateway to me
introducing some of that
back into my real life.
I've taken as an exercise
to just say, you know what,
I'm going to...
I'm gonna go on instinct.
I'm gonna be experiencing this moment.
I'm not gonna overthink it.
I'm not going to be so serious
or give into my anxiety
or whatever maybe is what is instinctively
in my normal life, the first concern
that would enter my mind but
then saying, you know what,
this is what it's like to have fun.
And I think the exercise of
doing the show builds the muscle
of being able to let loose
a little bit and then...
So in the way that I play
with the kids or hang out
with Christy or when I get home from work
and we're all hanging out in
the kitchen and it's like,
oh we're playing music, and you know what,
I'm just gonna, you
know what, let's dance.
We funneled so much of that energy
to your point of we're
boring into our work
that from a practical standpoint,
I felt like it's all
been drained out of me.
So I don't know maybe I'm
getting a little too--
- Well.
- I'm just trying to,
I'm actually trying to harness
that in my every day life
to just become generally stupid.
- Well I think--
- But you know what I mean.
- I think what I was saying was that
people might expect that if
I were to just watch Rhett
and Link having a
conversation with each other,
then it would be--
- Hilarious.
- It would be hilarious
and as entertaining
as an Ear Biscuit.
- Right.
- When in reality, it would
probably be as entertaining
as the last half hour of this Ear Biscuit,
you know what I'm saying, which,
you might be like oh
this is the good stuff.
They got very real.
But you probably didn't last a whole lot
in the past 30 minutes.
I'm just saying that that's
kinda how we talk to each other.
For me...
I feel like for me it's not a question
of I don't have enough personality
left over for my family.
A lot of times it's
just an energy question
or a time question because
I gotta work on this thing.
Even though I'm at home
I gotta finish this thing
and that's a problem, but that's not,
that's a different problem,
that's like a time management problem.
- I wasn't directing any of it at you.
I think that the moments
where we just embrace
the sheer joy of what happens on the show
and we heighten it I think
is a skill that was like,
okay, how can this cycle back ironically
and the life could imitate art
and I could benefit from it.
So it was an interesting thought exercise.
- Well along the same lines,
I don't even know if you
were in this conversation
with some of our close friends,
we were talking about...
I'm trying to figure out some things
in therapy like we've been talking about,
like being able to understand
what my emotions are
and deal with feelings
and that kinda thing.
But I think part of that is like we have,
we've got a friend group
and there's a very high
emotional intelligence
in our friend group.
Like significantly higher
than I have sort of
been close to for the majority of my life.
- Mm-hmm.
- Not judging you.
Just saying just in terms
of like greater friendships or whatever.
And I mean they're all legitimately
just intelligent people
but they're also emotionally intelligent
and what I mean by that
is somebody's going
through something or
somebody shares something
and they just have just a level of insight
and perspective that I'm
kind of used to being,
I like kinda being the
guy who knows things
in the room, right, you know that
and it annoys you.
And I understand that.
But like, then a lot of places,
I am the guy who knows
things in the room, right?
I'm not an expert on
anything but I know a lot
about a lot of things and
so I tend to feel like
I've got something to contribute
but a lot of times with the group
that we've gotten really close with,
they're so emotionally intelligent
that I start to kinda feel like an idiot.
And I'm like, I don't know
how to comfort this person.
I don't know what to say in this situation
because that's not how my brain works.
I haven't figured that out yet
and so I'm just gonna kinda be quiet.
And I've also done a
second level of analysis.
Again, we've hinted at the Enneagram
and we will do an episode
about it at some point.
But again it's the personality evaluation
where there's nine
different personality types.
I'm a three on the Enneagram
which means I'm a performer,
an achiever and one of the
things that the threes do is
that if they are not good at something,
they don't play the game.
And so, engaging on an emotional level
with somebody is something I'm not good at
so I just don't do it.
Because I do the things that I can win at
and that is a, and I
didn't really understand
that's how my personality worked
until I started reading more in depth
about the way threes are and it's like,
if they don't have a good
chance of winning the game,
they do not participate.
And they can actually
be incredibly successful
because they are good at a lot of things
and they also only do the
things they're good at
so you see them and you're
like, man they're good
at all the things that they do
until you put them in an
environment where they have
to behave differently so
the way this translates
to the difference between me on the show
and me in real life is that
when I get into those situations
where I feel like it's a
more intimate atmosphere,
I become the quiet one.
Where on the show, there's no opportunity
to be the quiet one.
Neither one of us is the quiet one.
We both could talk 100 miles an hour.
We talk over each other
constantly because we both want
to be the ones to get the last word in.
I think we both suffer
from that and that's one
of the things that
contributes to why we do
what we do and we do it well.
And so the thing I told our friends
when I was talking is I
actually think that my true self
is more represented in
the context of what I do
as an entertainer than it is
when I'm just in real life.
When I am my more
happy-go-lucky, in the moment,
reacting, laughing, trying
to make people laugh,
thing that I do on the show,
and even in the context of
this, I'm still on a little bit.
- Yeah.
- My on
is actually--
- Letting something out.
- A truer connection with who I am.
It isn't putting something on.
In fact, the mask and
the facade is the quiet,
reserved Rhett who is afraid to enter
into a certain situation
for fear of not being able
to win that situation because
I frame it in the wrong way.
- That's exactly what I'm talking about.
I think yeah, within
the context of the show,
you can experience legitimate
emotion within a certain,
a subset of emotions, right,
that are like elation,
as an example.
- Well I think it goes to--
- It's a discovery.
- Show you that--
- Surprise.
- Unbelievably--
- Pain.
- And thankfully.
- Happiness.
- We've created an environment on the show
where we can be so
comfortable, 'cause again,
this is the thing that we
didn't get when we did,
like if you go back and watch
the old Online Nation clips,
you look at that and you're
like, we were not comfortable.
- Oh no.
- Right?
It was the peak of the evidence
that there is out there
of us not being comfortable
in a entertainment setting.
- Yeah.
- But this show and GMM also
represent these environments
that we've created and we've been able
to completely shape the
environment so that we can just
be our true selves.
So it is ironic that it
seems like oh you're on
and you're acting, but my
theory and I hear you saying
the same thing is that well, actually,
that's who I am and when I go out
and I navigate the real
world, I turn that,
it isn't that I turn it
on when I'm on the show,
it's that I turn it off
when I'm in real life.
- Yeah I think that we've...
I think my question to the listener
or to the Mythical Beasts
watching GMM who complains
about things that maybe
they're missing the comedy
or they're misinterpreting
a comedic choice
as an honest moment and
then being disappointed
and then being critical of it,
I'm asking them to
expand the way they view
our performance in the show,
to not shift but to include those things.
I think that's what I'm asking of them.
And I know that it
frustrates you a little more
than it does to me because it kinda,
as we've discussed, it goes to you.
But I think for you maybe
there's an opportunity
to see, I think you just
described the beauty
of what the show,
the opportunity it gives you as a person
and me as a person to
experience things that can then
inspire who we are in our normal lives.
And those are the things
that people, they latch,
those true moments, if they
latch onto them so hard
and make them so precious
that they can't take
the other comedic bits, it's like,
you can't fault 'em for it.
Because it's also a very,
it's kind of the heart
and soul of our show because like--
- We've created an environment
where we're authentic
and so then to get upset with them
for being, for doing a
character or doing a bit
and having a problem with it, it's yeah.
- It's kind of a meeting in the middle.
- I just wanna have my
cake and eat it too.
- Yeah taking that criticism as an,
you can invert it as a
compliment that like,
the thing that attracts them
to the show is the heart
and soul of the show and it's
our true selves coming through
and they can't even take
it when we make a choice
that deviates from it so--
- I think--
- Maybe that'll just help,
just help you process it.
- Well and also we talked about
this a little bit is I think
that unfortunately the
people who have an issue
with these types of things
are also for whatever reason,
the personality profile
is they're more likely
to engage online, and so the people
who might actually appreciate--
- And I think ultimately
we're different people
and I think better people
because of fielding that.
As painful or frustrating
as it may be sometimes too,
so I'll even go that for.
You need to be thankful for it.
- I don't disagree with
that I'm just saying that
one of the things that
makes it difficult is that
I know that there are people
out there who appreciate
but you're likely to get
a comment about something
that they don't like than they do like.
We get so many, when we meet
fans in meet and greet lines
at shows, I'm always surprised
with how many people have
Cotton Candy Randy t-shirts on
and say I love Cotton Candy Randy.
And I'm like well why
don't you say something
on the internet about it? (laughs)
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, and so--
- Well do you want a
comment or do you want them
to buy a shirt?
- Well how about both?
No but you're right and again,
I also don't wanna make it seem like,
I mean I'm talking about these things
because you asked this question.
And I talked about it the
other day because it was
in the context of the conversation
that we were having.
I don't spend a significant
portion of my time,
like not even a, I don't even
spend an insignificant portion
of my time, like I spend
barely any time thinking
about this particular thing
and being frustrated about it.
I spend--
- Yeah.
We didn't talk about it after that moment.
- Yeah I spend the vast
majority of my time
just trying to come up with
something to entertain.
And that's pretty much
probably to a fault,
that's what I do with
almost all of my time.
So I don't, I'm not sitting around stewing
about any of this stuff,
it's just, if you bring it up
and then you start talking about it,
I get a little frustrated about it.
But I don't sit around
frustrated on a regular basis
about it so I don't want
anybody to think that,
so no need to apologize to
me if you've said things
and you're like, oh I feel bad.
I told Rhett he was mean,
I need to apologize to him.
I don't need your apologies.
And I'm gonna be okay.
- All right guys, thank
you for hanging out with us
and allowing us to psychoanalyze
ourselves and each other.
Let us know, #EarBiscuits,
whatever you wanna let us know.
Weigh in on the conversation.
We appreciate that.
Tell people about this podcast
so they can listen to it too.
- How would you describe it?
- Let us know, #EarBiscuits.
- Describe it to a friend and then tell us
how you described it and
tell us what they say.
- That's good.
That's good, speak at you next week.
(electronic music)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)